heading out anywhere going hiking or any plans or you know just chill back and
relax for the longer be yeah so I'm in Austin Texas and my sister lives in
Pensacola Florida so I'm flying out tomorrow to go visit her for a couple
days so alright so yeah good word to being by the beach Florida is good sunny
this time of the year I believe not too hot I've been hearing good details about
it yeah I grew up in Florida so it'll be nice to go back for I think I'll be
there for about four or five days and my parents are gonna drive in too so it'll
be nice to see family so you want to go surfing or no I wish I could surf I can't
but I'll definitely be going to the beach I'll get into the ocean and just swim
around all right so here's to cheers to the upcoming week that you're gonna have
and enjoy your stay yeah thank you and have some you know good homemade food
hopefully that's that's what I'm looking forward to all right I'm sorry I
completely derailed the entire conversation with the entire man is let
me give a quick intro about myself I believe you already had a little bit of
intro and then if you could you know say a couple of details about yourself and
then we jump right into it if that sounds all right yeah that sounds great
cool so Himachal this side I look off to the entire partnership ecosystem over
here at Shortills being with the firm for a little over a year at this point for
myself I started out as a cyber security consultant I did some work with EY you
know worked over there for BFSI and primarily pharma customers so did some
sort of did some cyber security work with there for a couple of years and then
transitioned into more of a business consulting role so provided consulting
services for US based healthcare and financial services customers and I
don't know a stroke of luck so an opportunity in data analytics and AI
jumped on that bandwagon and have been you know kind of trying to just ensure
that I do not fall off the decent changes that a through every month also so
that's got it yeah super nice to meet you yeah
um Prathim I don't know if you wanted to do an intro where I can go ahead
awesome yeah nice to meet you guys and glad we could connect I've been at click
for about four years now I started out on the BDR team for I think it was about
10 months to a year and then moved up to an account executive a few years ago
but yeah my territory is right now it's in Texas which is good because it's
local so I cover just three major cities in Texas which is Austin Houston and
San Antonio and then all of the state of Louisiana I'm still just getting used to
my territory because they just did some transitions I click and they switched
up basically my whole team's territory so we just got these new ones about a
month or so ago so just trying to get the land the land a little bit and reach
out to the customers and just kind of jumpstart all those relationships but
yeah I've lived in Austin for about the same four years I moved here for a job
and I grew up in Jacksonville Florida but yeah super nice to meet you guys again
all right so Natalie it's lovely to connect with you as well so just wanted
to have a little bit of an introductory call get to know the other person and give
a little bit of an intro about Shortills as well so we have been we have
recently started the partnership with click and you know we have been trying
to strengthen that up we have our partners with click but we have been
more involved in the professional services side of the stuff so we have
been working very with the the South situation the Singapore click team for
the professional aspects for you know in the entire APJ region so delivering you
know workloads on some of the things that we have seen most most you know
requested out of the gate are hey let's have some of the click predict use cases
that we can showcase to the end customer because at the end of the day what I
believe is the recent mandate that is going around is for let's start pushing
or click predict as well as click answer that option so we have been working
primarily on click predict use cases so that entails data modeling all of the
other good stuff with visualization and the other aspect that we have been
focused on is the talent piece so you know creating those custom pipelines
through talent and ensuring those can be delivered for be we have worked
primarily in the packing sector for talent so talent is in BFSI with click
sense we have much more experience with the entire ecosystem across the
different verticals so that's which that is the experience that we kind of carry
at this point of time. Got it have you guys been working with any of the other
click reps yet? We are you know setting out on that path. Got it. So the most recent the
current deliveries that are going on from my side are primarily along the lines
for you know financial services customer an automotive customer and what is it
yeah two financial services customers and one automotive customer over where I am
working on click so it is talent then click sense and predict use cases so
these are the core areas we have been working on right now for you know
together with click. And do you have knowledge on the full like end-to-end
scope of quick talent cloud and click cloud analytics? Yeah we have managed to
build it out. Okay got it yeah just want to keep that in mind as I get some
opportunities that need some help on the services side so I know which ones to
bring to which partners it's helpful to know and then in terms of different
industries is there do you have a focus on the financial services and the
automotive or is that just kind of the companies you're working with right now?
It is kind of what we have been working together with the click-perfect
question services are primarily because we predict is a use case which generally is
more adoptive for at least from what we have heard with them is for the
automotive as well as the financial services side they are much a little bit
more receptive. With the financial services side we have seen a little bit a
different track going out as well so that has been for click answers so click
answers is a great platform if you are you know on cloud but a lot of the BFSI
customers they are not willing to go on to the cloud environment so they are not
going to go on to click answers so they are looking at hey do you have anything
that you have that provides the click answers capability for an on-prem
deployment? I believe you're looking at solution out of the way as well or
released in the upcoming months but we started working on that roughly about
three three and a half months back and we successfully showcased it to the
click team as well it was taken forward to the customer and then just last
week we heard that hey click is also going to come out with a click answers
platform and so that kind of orange but hey at least we learned a little bit
more about click answers and how it functions. Yeah for sure and you're
talking about when you say click answers are you just talking about the on and
on-premises version of it for the for customers that don't want to go into the
cloud or are you talking about the cloud version? So click answers is a completely
cloud offering right? Yeah yeah. We created an on-prem version for it. We replicated the
first thing of click answers for an on-prem customer. Okay next that's what I
thought you're saying just wanted to double confirm but got it and then in
terms of I know we talked about industries for a second is there any
that you have more experience or expertise in that maybe would be helpful
in targeting and I just ask because the way that like when I get an opportunity
and or when my BDRs out prospecting for me I pick a partner just based on we
have a bunch of different partners and some of them have a different industry
focus or a different piece of click that they're more comfortable.
with so that just kind of helps me assign in my head like what account should go to which partner.
So just want to know if there's anything like that for you guys.
For us, we have primarily more experience with the accounting side of the stuff.
So we've been working together with one of the big fours.
We created the complete platform for them.
Apart from that, we have a lot more experience in the digital related space as well as in the
BFSI space.
So BFSI and that is a little bit of pedigree that we have built up the accounting firm.
So it has you know, seep in.
So BFSI and DnB digital related businesses.
That is one of the two of the core areas that we look at.
Okay, got it.
And are there, do you guys have any like slides or any resources that you could share just
so I can kind of look over them and share them with any customers or potential customers
that I get into opportunities with?
Sure, I can send it forward to you.
Awesome.
Yeah, that would be great.
And then I'll look through those and I can let you know if I just have any questions.
And if I do get an opportunity that kind of fits on what we've talked about, then I can
always reach out and just double check and make sure that it's something that you guys
can work with too.
Sure.
Sounds good.
So Natalie, just one thing.
So you're looking after Austin, Houston, and you mentioned one more place.
Yeah, San Antonio.
San Antonio.
So are you looking after any specific verticals or is it hey, all the verticals in this particular
geography?
Yeah, it's all verticals.
So on the commercial side, we can go after any company in our territory that has a revenue
of zero to one billion.
And then our customer base, like the accounts that are already customers with click is 25K
spend a year in the under.
Okay.
Yeah.
So those are the accounts that we're trying to upsell or process through.
But in terms of white space accounts, it's any vertical, any industry, it just has to
be in our territory and within the revenue limitations.
Got it.
So just thinking out loud, you can let me know if this sounds like something that would
be feasible or not.
If you're looking at a green field or an activated account, so customer who's already
in $25,000 or plus.
So if you're looking to cross-sell into that account, are you looking to focus on click
predict or is that not one of the co-focus areas for you?
I think my core focus, it's definitely been a part of the core focus because the main
message, I guess, is more of a move to cloud and the AI capabilities are the number one
attention grabbers to do so.
So it definitely has been in the mix of part of the core messaging that goes out to those
accounts.
So the reason I pitched forward for that is if there is an existing account or an attributed
account, which is already on click, click predict, they might be able to start, ideally,
they should be able to start taking it off, utilizing it right off the bat.
But what I've seen is customers are a little bit slow on the uptake and they need a little
bit of hand-holding to really take full advantage of click predict.
Even though the click predict is supposed to be, hey, it is supposed to be for business
users, but just what we have seen with our previous customers that we have delivered
for, a little bit of use case demonstration goes a long way for them to go forward with
a longer adoption of just one use case to them, and that makes way for three or four
other use cases that can be taken forward.
Got it.
And so you're saying like people who have already made the move over to get the click
predict capabilities, you would want to jump in and kind of work with them to sell them
services to get their click predict up and running?
That is one aspect.
The other one is if the customer is already on click, they might not be using click predict.
And if you're having any sort of, if they're looking to have data modeling over there,
hey, what is going to be my next year's revenue on the basis of my previous year?
So what is the performance of my different business units and how it is going about
because of these different metrics?
How is it really impacting me down the line?
So this is some sort of a data modeling problem that can be addressed by click predict.
So this is something that you hear from any of the customer.
Maybe if you then you would be more inclined to pitch click predict to them in that scenario,
if it makes sense, we would be, we can maybe do a small POC for them.
We can, I can push forward my team.
I can bring in my data scientist into that particular engagement and build out that use
case for them, one particular use case for them within a timeframe window that, hey,
within two weeks, we'll build out that use case.
And then we'll showcase it to them.
If it strikes the right chord with the customer, then it is obviously going to be much further
deployment architecture.
I mean, they'll look forward for other use cases, adoption as well.
So that would be increased for you and that would result in more services being leveraged on my part.
Got it.
Yeah, that makes sense.
Yeah, yeah, I followed that.
I'll definitely keep an ear out for any customers or potential customers that I talk to that say that
that's kind of an issue and where that would be a good fit.
Sounds good.
And the other thing that I was thinking out loud is you are having a little bit of, you know,
you have a lot of ground that you were looking to cover up in the, you know, maybe within the ear or so.
So if you have any particular accounts that you are looking to focus upon, maybe say in the upcoming
quarter, within this quarter itself, hey, these are maybe say 20 odd accounts where you're looking
to focus upon.
If you think that you can share that list with me, hey, if you're able to set up that conversation
or discussion with that particular customer, we can take it to the table.
It can be a triparty conversation between you from click, us from short hills and then obviously
the customer or the prospect at this point of time.
And we have that conversation and see where it goes.
Yeah, I can take a look at my account list.
I'm working with some partners on a few different verticals.
So let me go into the account list and kind of separate between the industries and see
which ones make the most sense and which ones I'm not already touching with the other partners.
And then maybe we can go in and attack that side.
Sounds good.
And Natalie, just one more thing.
Are you looking after, by any chance, are you looking after the healthcare and life sciences
segment HLS or, hey, not really something that you have seen any sort of traction over there?
Yeah, we have.
I've been working with another partner on the healthcare side of things.
I just started working with them on the new territory about a month or so ago.
So I can see kind of just how that plays out and if I'm able to get anything out of working
with them.
But if not, we can definitely move over and kind of change the messaging to be more short hills too.
All right, sounds good.
So it's just that I have taken up a little bit of a personal project of mine that, hey,
I'm looking to get into the healthcare and life sciences segment in the midwest area.
Just trying to work out how can I do that.
So we are established in UK, but midwest has been a little bit of uphill climb.
Got it.
Yeah.
This is a better index because of the entire Boston corridor that comes in.
But midwest has been a little bit of uphill climb.
Yeah, got it.
Yeah, I have a really large account list on the prospect side.
So I might even have some healthcare companies that are on the list that I shared with the other
partner.
So I can go through and see if I can put together a list from those that we are prospecting into yet
because it doesn't hurt to have two different messaging going out to different prospects.
So yeah, I can do that too once I take a look at the list.
Sure.
So I won't be able to commit to that, hey, I would be able to establish 100 odd communications.
I would be looking to have a little bit more of a whatever the list of 20 or so accounts
that you shared with me.
I'll be looking to have much more of an immediate closure action on maybe say three or four of them
and aggressively pursuing them rather than boiling the ocean with the entire list.
That is just I look at things.
Let me know if that works out for you.
Yeah, that works for me.
This is all actually that I had that I wanted to really
by you and understand how we can work jointly. Awesome. Yeah, it was great to connect with you guys
and great to learn a little bit more about short hills and hopefully we can work together and bring
in some more opportunities. Sounds good. So I'll be returning back six more minutes so that you
can go ahead and complete your packing for your week long trip and have a good rest of your day.
All right, we'll do. Bye. Bye.